[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toutes les personnes assises et nous
avons le droit de participer à la
construction de ce monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je me battrai coûte que coûte donc
le nom mon frère reste dans l'histoire
on a fait d'adama un symbole on a fait
on a fait des symboles des violences
policières en france
moi je veux qu'on me dise dans 15 ans
dans 20 ans dans 50 ans il y avait un
combat et le c'était le combat vérité et
justice pour un hamac qui a renversé un
système je me dis si aujourd'hui ch avec
vous dans mon serment en tant que femme
déjà en tant que femme noire c'est des
personnes sont battus pour que je puisse
garder ce droit là et avoir ce droit là
[Musique]
fini les populations afro descendantes
encore dit
[Musique]